anus it was after midnight in islamabad
where members of parliament voted on the
motion of no confidence
after a nearly 14-hour standoff between
imran khan's ruling party and the
opposition
174 members
have recorded their votes in favor of
the resolution
consequently
the resolution for vote of no confidence
against mr imran khan the prime minister
of islamic republic of pakistan has been
passed by a majority
of the total membership of the national
assembly
[Applause]
khan is the first prime minister in
pakistan to be ousted by a no-confidence
vote
opposition leader
sharif who's likely to succeed him said
pakistan had been freed from a crisis
a new dawn has started a new day is
coming allah has answered the prayers of
millions of pakistani mothers sisters
daughters elders and youth
khan says he won't accept an opposition
government and blames the u.s for
leading a conspiracy to remove him he's
called on his supporters to hold
nationwide rallies
imran khan has been removed to a foreign
conspiracy god willing we will fight
back to make him prime minister again we
don't want these thieves
khan's removal is the culmination of
months of political turmoil and a
week-long constitutional crisis the
opposition put forward a no-confidence
motion to parliament last sunday
but the deputy speaker blocked the
motion saying it was unconstitutional
and involved foreign interference
on khan's advice pakistan's president
dissolved parliament but the supreme
court ruled that was illegal
while imran has lost the battle in the
parliament he still has a large
following in the field especially among
the young and they are fairly committed
so a lot will depend how this
group under imran khan is going to
react or interact with the new
government because overnight the new
government will not be able to solve the
problems of the economy the relationship
with the military
the u.s state department has denied any
involvement in pakistan's internal
politics parliament will meet on monday
to appoint a new prime minister
victoria gatenbee al jazeera